[Aplausos]
[Música]
el día 1 de diciembre del año 2001 es un
día que ha quedado grabado a fuego en la
memoria colectiva del pueblo argentino
ese día el entonces ministro de economía
domingo felipe cavallo anunciaba la
puesta en marcha de la congelación de
los depósitos bancarios popularmente
conocido como el corralito a partir de
ese momento los argentinos no podían
sacar más de 250 pesos y en aquel
momento 250 dólares de sus cuentas en el
banco por supuesto la reacción popular
no se hizo esperar y durante días las
protestas crecieron sin parar
[Música]
la imagen icónica que ha quedado para el
recuerdo ha sido la de grupos de
personas agrupadas frente a las
sucursales y sedes bancarias golpeando
cacerolas y exigiendo la devolución
total de sus depósitos queridos amigos
amigas el caos fue tan grande que poco
más de dos semanas después que el día 20
de diciembre el por aquel entonces
presidente fernando de la rúa se vio
obligado a dimitir tras una dura jornada
de protestas en la plaza de mayo- una
jornada de protestas que se saldó con al
menos 29 personas fallecidas 20 años
después en visual político nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas porque se
produjo exactamente el corralito cuáles
fueron los verdaderos motivos de la
mayor crisis económica en la historia de
la argentina y quizás la pregunta más
importante de todas existe acaso la
posibilidad de que volvamos a ver una
situación similar atentos
[Música]
camino al abismo
sabéis que en visual político nos
encanta la argentina y que queréis que
os diga creo que si algo ha quedado
claro tras la ya larga lista de vídeos
que hemos publicado sobre este país con
esteban ya ni más ni menos que 21 es la
clara predilección que la argentina
tiene por tener un gobierno gigantesco y
no no nos engañemos en la práctica sólo
existen tres formas de financiar un
gobierno enorme o una carga tributaria
ficciã ante un endeudamiento crónico o
una descontrolada emisión monetaria pues
bien a lo largo de la historia podemos
encontrar gobiernos que han tratado de
gastar a manos llenas recurriendo a una
de estas fuentes de financiación sin
embargo amigos lo particular del caso
argentino script de la década de 1940
prácticamente todos los gobiernos han
usado y abusados en tregua de estas tres
herramientas al mismo tiempo eso es lo
que explica la eterna crisis gaucha la
madre de todos los males de la
argentina- una constante de todos los
gobiernos de un color o de otro un gasto
público e inasumible una política que
desde los años 40 y mira que ha llovido
lleva cosechando los mismos resultados
siempre los mismos crisis crisis y
crisis porque amigos las cartas están
sobre la mesa
el problema con la deuda es que hay que
pagarle y refinanciar la y cuando no se
hace entonces la financiación escasea y
se encarece luego por el lado de la
presión tributaria sucede tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo al contraerse las
rentas del sector privado la recaudación
termina disminuyendo a medio plazo y
además alienta a la economía informal
por tanto a los diferentes gobiernos no
les quedó otra que echarse en brazos de
la emisión monetaria para mantener sus
políticas de más y más gasto público el
abuso de esta herramienta ha sido tal
que ha hecho que la inflación disparada
si a un mal crónico de la economía
argentina una economía que llegó a
experimentar un proceso de fortísima
hiperinflación entre 1989 y 1990 que tal
y como sostienen los economistas pablo
guido y gustavo lázzari esto supuso la
muerte del dinero
[Música]
tal y como ya os contamos en un pasado
vídeo titulado cuando la argentina quiso
volver a hacer rica el único momento
donde se dio la sensación de que
realmente el país quería cambiar de
rumbo fue bajo los gobiernos de carlos
saúl menem quien de la mano de su
ministro de economía domingo cavallo
puso en marcha un amplio proceso de
reformas incluyendo la privatización de
buena parte de las empresas públicas sin
embargo sin embargo lo que no
desapareció fue la madre de todos los
males el gasto público disparado
básicamente la única diferencia fue que
en lugar de financiarlo con inflación
esto es dándole una y otra y otra vez a
la máquina de imprimir billetes los
gobiernos de menem financiaron sus
políticas de gasto con el dinero
procedente de las privatizaciones
primero y luego con más y más
endeudamiento es decir que lo que hizo
menem fue apagar el incendio de la
hiperinflación de la presidencia cargó
alfonsín su antecesor en el cargo y dar
un golpe de timón a la economía
argentina pero no sacó adelante ni mucho
menos todos los cambios que el país
necesitaba para poder desplegar el gasto
público siguió creciendo la apertura con
mercosur pues fue muy limitada la
regulación siguió siendo excesiva
especialmente lo referente a la
legislación laboral porque para que os
hagáis una idea en argentina hacen tan
difícil y costoso crear empleos y al
final pues lógicamente no se crean y
cuando lo hace pues lo hace la economía
informal de cajón fijaos cómo estaban
las cosas allá por comienzos del nuevo
siglo
[Música]
por cada 100 pesos que figuran como
ingreso bruto en el recibo de un
trabajador solo 82 pesos van a su
bolsillo mientras tanto el empleador por
esos 100 pesos de ingreso bruto debe
abonar 133 pesos esto significa que por
cada 82 pesos que recibe efectivamente
un trabajador privado el empleador debe
abonar 133 pesos la diferencia un 62 por
ciento constituye una interminable
sumatoria de impuestos -pablo guido y
gustavo lázzari apuntes sobre la
economía argentina 2003 y ojo porque hoy
las cosas siguen igual o incluso peor
para colmo volviendo a la época de menem
muchas de las privatizaciones se
hicieron de tal forma que crearon
mercados cautivos que se quedaron en
manos de amigos del gobierno las cosas
mejoraron sí pero en el fondo pues no
tanto así que cuando menem dejó el
gobierno el país seguía teniendo muchos
pero que muchos problemas los argentinos
no lo sabían pero el corralito ya se
estaba gestando
[Música]
diciembre de 1999 fernando de la rúa se
convierte en el nuevo presidente de la
argentina la situación económica era ya
en aquel momento complicada era urgente
hacer ajustes por ejemplo para frenar el
agujero genérico agujero el boquete que
tenían las cuentas públicas y que
amenazaba con poner patas arriba toda la
economía el tictac hacia la destrucción
económica estaba en marcha y aquí amigos
os hago una pregunta qué demonios
pensáis que hizo de la rúa cómo quiso
enfrentarse al déficit público
recortando quizás el gasto público
ni de broma hablamos de argentina de
argentina de argentina la propuesta del
gobierno se basó básicamente en subir
los impuestos en lugar de recortar el
gasto para que os hagáis una idea de los
algo más de 7 mil millones de dólares de
ajuste en el déficit público incluidos
en el plan del gobierno para 2001 casi 6
mil millones correspondían a subidas de
impuestos poco más de 1.000 a control
del gasto es decir en una relación 80-20
claro que eso no es todo porque una cosa
es una propuesta política y otra muy
distinta a la realidad tras varias
crisis políticas en noviembre del 2000
de la rúa reconocía finalmente que la
disminución del déficit no sería ni
mucho menos la prevista y al mes
siguiente para colmo el congreso aprobó
un presupuesto con un de 7000 millones
de pesos es decir para entendernos un 70
por ciento más de lo anunciado por el
plan inicial del gobierno amigos el
tictac seguía en marcha y ya parecía
claro que el año 2001 sería muy pero que
muy difícil
en el año 2001 fue una catástrofe la
inversión cayó un 45 por ciento el
consumo casi un 10 y el desempleo no
paraba de subir la tasa de paro alcanzó
el 18% y las protestas lideradas por la
oposición peronista se recrudecieron de
la rúa enfrentó 8 paros nacionales en
sus dos años de gobierno en los que
también surgieron los piquetes esto es
grupos organizados ligados a sindicatos
que durante sus protestas cortan las
carreteras las calles y la actividad
económica en semejante contexto la
desconfianza era casi total lo que
provocó que los depósitos bancarios se
desplomaran un 20 por ciento nadie se
fiaba ya del futuro de la economía
argentina había que poner a salvo todo
lo que se pudiera
para intentar revertir la situación de
la rúa decidió colocar a un economista
partidario de ajustar el gasto público
ricardo lópez murphy al frente del
ministerio de economía duró 15 días
amigos al gobierno ya sólo le quedaba
una bala echarse en brazos del padre de
las reformas de la era menem domingo
felipe cavallo entonces para mantener el
gasto público se obligó a los bancos ya
los fondos de pensiones a comprar deuda
pública al tiempo que se aprobó un mega
canje para convertir deuda a corto plazo
en deuda a largo plazo con tipos de
intereses mayores lo que equivale a
decir patada para adelante es decir ya
lo veis todo tipo de malabares con tal
de no meter la mano donde hacía falta al
gasto público que esperaban que esa vez
ocurrir algo diferente pues
evidentemente no
[Música]
era una situación imposible el gobierno
ya no tenía activos valiosos que
privatizar y lograr dinero la
financiación internacional estaba
cerrada el fondo monetario internacional
dijo que sin recortes de gasto no
contarán con el cris y el gobierno
recurrí a la emisión monetaria esto es
el banco central la gente enseguida
corre a cambiar sus pesos por dólares
ante lo que pudiera pasar lo que hacía
más difícil mantener el tipo de cambio
al tiempo que se reducían las reservas
de divisas las cosas iban de mal en peor
ya sólo quedaba esperar el estallido de
la crisis
explosión
[Música]
los argentinos sabían que la situación
era de extrema gravedad entre enero y
noviembre de 2001 los depósitos
bancarios cayeron en otros 20 mil
millones de pesos el equivalente a 20
mil millones de dólares de ello 2 mil
500 millones fueron retirados de los
bancos el viernes 30 de noviembre era un
ritmo insostenible así que la solución
del gobierno fue decretar un feriado
bancario y restringir el retiro de
dinero de las cajas de ahorros y cuentas
corrientes la medida se anunció el
sábado 1 de diciembre y comenzó a regir
el lunes 3 se estableció un límite de
retiro de 250 pesos semanales por cuenta
bancaria es decir que si uno tenía diez
mil pesos en su cuenta del banco sólo
podía acceder a 250 por semana y ojo
porque luego se redujo a 2 el número
máximo de cuentas bancarias que una
persona podía tener a apunte el resto
del dinero se podría utilizar por medio
de tarjetas de débito u operaciones
electrónicas pero claro tenemos que
tener en cuenta que a finales del 2001
era muy poca la gente que realizaba ese
tipo de operaciones en argentina esto
fue el corralito un corralito que según
lo aprobado por el gobierno teniendo
vigencia de 90 días claro que esos tres
meses fueron suficientes para cambiar la
historia del país y causar un daño
económico irreparable
la medida provocó el efecto opuesto al
que perseguía al gobierno en lugar de
generar tranquilidad generó
incertidumbre caos la medida hundió el
consumo ya muchas pequeñas empresas pero
además los argentinos empezaban a
comprender lo que suponía perder sus
ahorros de un día para otro pues porque
el fin de la convertibilidad uno a uno
con el dólar que iba a suponer
irremediablemente una tremenda
devaluación del peso argentino de ahí la
urgencia por sacar el dinero o sacabas
tus ahorros o los perdí así como el
gobierno no te dejaba sacarlo era una
especie de ruina cámara lenta
el gobierno en ese momento buscó el
rescate del fmi pero cuando cabal o
viajo eeuu se encontró con una respuesta
tajante que no que no que no nos contáis
películas sino órdenes las cuentas
públicas y recortes el gasto público de
una puñetera vez nosotros el fm y no
vamos a poner más dinero de ninguna
manera ni de broma pronto la situación
degeneró a tal nivel que la
desesperación los saqueos los choques
con la policía se hicieron cotidianos
finalmente el 19 de diciembre el
presidente de la rúa ante la
imposibilidad de contener las protestas
y los saqueos decretó el estado de sitio
el mismo instrumento del que se habían
valido las diferentes dictaduras
militares de argentina para controlar a
la población supuso arrojar gasolina al
fuego y tan sólo un día más tarde el 20
de diciembre los enfrentamientos con las
fuerzas del orden dejaron 29 fallecidos
el gobierno estaba acabado minutos antes
de las 20 horas el presidente presentó
su renuncia y se alejó de la casa
rosada- en un helicóptero
[Música]
dolor y ruina
desde la rúa el poder paso a ramón
puerta luego 3 días después la asamblea
legislativa eligió presidente al
gobernador de la provincia de san luis
adolfo rodríguez saá quien por cierto
ostentó el cargo apenas siete días antes
de renunciar desde el 23 al 30 de
diciembre período que aprovecho eso sí
para declarar el default de la deuda
externa ante el aplauso unánime de todo
el congreso aunque felicidad luego el
poder cayó en manos de eduardo camaño y
finalmente en eduardo duhalde un
sindicado que había alentado las
protestas y que asumió el cargo el 1 de
enero del 2002 en menos de 10 días
amigos de argentina tuvo cinco jefes de
estados diferentes fueron las horas más
negras del país durante los siguientes
meses la pobreza se multiplicó el peso
se siguió evaluando y pasó de 11 a 13
los depósitos no se devolvieron a los
que tenían dólares en el banco se los
robaron se los cambiaron por pesos que
cada vez valía menos y por supuesto todo
esto supuso el fin del peso y del
sistema financiero argentino nadie en su
sano juicio volvería a dejar sus ahorros
en manos de los políticos de este país
y qué queréis que os diga razones no
faltaban de hecho la historia parece
clara desde entonces las cosas no han
mejorado mucho veinte años después
argentinas siguen las mismas el país
está más endeudado que nunca tiene la
mayor presión impositiva de la historia
y la inflación anual supera el 50 por
ciento es lo que ya se conoce como la
tragedia argentina pero amigos llegado
hasta aquí turno para ti en esta ocasión
voy a hacer crudo y directo que es que
la argentina tiene solución déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabes si este resultado
interesante y no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual política y hoy en
especial un abrazo muy fuerte a todos
los que nos veis desde ese país que a
pesar de todo sigue siendo tan
maravilloso la argentina
[Música]